françois avard c'est un habitué du
service des archives de radio-canada
on le connaît comme auteur dé boucan
pour son travail avec des humoristes
il est aussi scénariste de l'émission
les enfants de la télé
et qu'est ce qu'ils viennent de faire
des enfants de la télé ça fait une
spéciale de deux heures sur les 50 ans
de l'émission bye bye
c'est françois avard et son équipe qui
ont choisi tous les extraits à partir
des émissions diffusées au cours des 50
dernières années
quoique on assista alors les bye bye
françois va y connaît surtout qu'il a
lui-même travaillé au sketch de cette
bye bye
entre 2008 et 2015 l'époque de louis
morissette avec véronique cloutier
hélène bourgeois-leclerc joël legendre
et les autres listes m'ont promis quoi
j'ai pas de folles j'ai tué deux femmes
un des grands studios de radio-canada de
son expérience on peut tirer quelques
enseignements
par exemple c'est quoi un bon sketch
idéalement un bon sketch bye bye c'est
un sketch kick et drôle qui critique et
qui rejoint le plus de gens possible le
pipeline va traverser de nombreux cours
d'eau
c'est très dangereux on s'en fout de
l'eau si tu veux de lotina sur marche
sinon en vente à l'épicerie les de plus
en plus difficile de trouver des sujets
que tous se connaissent les jeunes
n'écoutent plus la télé d'autres regards
des séries américaines
c'est l'argent qui n'est alors par
exemple quand véronique tutti a fait un
pastiche du vidéoclip de lady gaga
combien de téléspectateurs pouvaient
juger du réalisme de limitation mois
quand les gars en parler autour de la
table de soi moi j'avais jamais vu et on
est on est plusieurs à avoir vu le clip
qui tenait le bye bye gamin à l'époque
de michael jackson où tout le monde
avait vu on avait vu le nom dans
l'exemple de lady gaga pour rejoindre
plus de monde
on a voulu que les images s'adresse aux
jeunes
alors que le texte lui vise un autre
public en parlant de corruption
politique
kaka qui marche
en plus mal
on est
arrête un blabla comment se construit un
sketch on trouve d'abord un événement et
ensuite on établit dans quel contexte
évolueront les personnages le problème
les daims dans quel contexte
étonnant on peut placer tel politicien
pour que ça aille plus de répercussions
plus d'originalité que d'un vrai que ce
soit drôle 44 millions des poubelles
trouver les gags ça vient après on peut
pas écrire on peut pas partir d'un punch
line puis a grandi
une fois que la scène est établi le
concept du sketch est établi chacun va
retourner chez eux avec sedan tête puis
va trouver des gars qui ont choisi les
meilleurs puis quand on sait lire
ensemble parce que dans les réunions on
se lit les textes de l'un de l'autre et
ont rebondi sur le texte à meaux ça
m'inspire ce pop m6 à sa place quand on
a les textes
la machine infernale est lancée via de
tournage commence puis gelé les avocats
de radio-canada qui regardent les textes
qui nous reviennent là-dessus
la direction du canada et le producteur
et les budgets et les avocats du
producteur et de la pression énormément
de pression en plus louis morissette a
introduit ce qu'on appelle le focus
group
fin décembre on montre un groupe choisi
de spectateurs une version préliminaire
du bye bye
s'il ne rit pas ou sont offensés par un
sketch il ne sera pas diffusée
l'objectif c'est de fournir la meilleure
émission possible parce que c'est
l'émission la plus regardée scom du
rodage un hymne au risque du rodage de
son spectacle et qui s'assure que au
soir de la première tout ce qui est tapé
dans l'oeil été enlevé parce qu'on l'a
bien tester mais pas moyen de rands soit
drôle quelques sketches enlever des
corrections dernières minutes et c'est
la diffusion le 31 décembre
tu vis toujours on vise toujours de
faire faire le meilleur bye bye le bye
bye du siècle puis année après année on
réalise que nous nous comme d'habitude
50% des jeunes combiné messieurs que 50%
des gens qui ont une peau et maison que
c'était meilleur avant sa meilleure
année possible l'année passée samangan
qu'il faisait il nous semblait donc vous
l'aviez pas aimé non plus malgré le bye
bye c'est un gros navire qui vogue sur
une mer agitée où chaque membre
d'équipage a son rôle à jouer
nous c'est de trouver la nounou trident
dans la vie quotidienne dans ce qui nous
entoure de dénoncer ce qui dérange le ce
qui agace de soulever d'aider des choses
qui vont pas ensemble les illogismes de
la vie et de toute cette aventure
quel aura été le meilleur sketch de
françois avard antoine bertrand qui
parodiait la chanson de chez picquier
sur une boule oui mais guère d'effet
c'est celui dont il est le plus fier
parce que ses filles l'ont adoré ça les
faisait ayant appris la chanson par cas
qui peut-être pas une bonne idée à l'âge
que j'avais mais pour moi il y avait
quelque chose de haye
ce sur quoi peut pas travailler les
sentries puis je te rebond notamment où
aboutit aussi la rp antoine était très
bon si pour faire vite
[Musique]
et dire que déjà il y avait de la nudité
en 68 au premier bye bye bye bye on les
aime pour les déteste toujours on les
regarde
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]